what was our two worst Food experiences
one the expensive ones yeah the most
expensive meals that we had were
actually our worst experiences and um if
I could kind of quantify why no matter
where you go there's a certain level of
snobbery to New Age chefs right they
feel in five four three two one Ohio
goes I must everybody we are back from
Japan
um so if you I'm sorry let me just redo
that once again
welcome to the genius brain podcast
everybody I am your host David so and we
have my lovely wife if you don't know
usually when I mischedule podcasts
yeah so we have a lot of things going on
right now we're in the process of moving
we're doing a whole bunch of stuff so
well that's hot news yeah so we are I
gotta I gotta get this done before I go
to Hawaii you know June B Hawaii make
sure you guys check that out
um and I said on a podcast which I don't
know if this is going to be a great
topic to have on the podcast but I do
know a lot of people are going to Japan
right and I'm very blessed because Mario
lived in Japan she speaks Japanese
uh decently enough where we can get
around so I basically don't have to do
any work at all so I'm there I just get
to follow around now mind you I have
been to Japan without her but when you
speak Japanese things just go literally
three times faster so instead of having
to sit there and translate things back
and forth which a lot of people in Japan
do speak English now
um specifically in Tokyo which I was
actually shocked as [__] to be honest
with you
um I I it totally went over my head
because I was just in my mode of talk to
them in their language get the answer
yeah because I remember when we were at
the uh the matcha shop right the one
with the cake or whatever yeah yeah yeah
and the guy spoke perfect English I was
like yo what the [__] is that that never
happened before like every spot I went
to in Tokyo without a single person
spoke English and so how and if they did
speak English it was
it was just enough to like communicate
barely but that guy was hyper fluent so
definitely I think just because of
Tourism alone or maybe it's like a job
requirement that people are now I mean
nowadays it's just a lot more common for
folks to learn English I mean it's a lot
easier to learn English too now that we
have like smartphones Netflix yeah you
know the popular stuff
um but like when we went to like
Universal Studio in Osaka
I went up to those employees and I was
like do you speak English and they're
like uh I'll try but then they even said
that in Japanese I was like okay well
might as well just talk to them in
Japanese it's like half half but it's a
lot more than when even when I was there
probably about five years ago it's
definitely a lot more convenient for
foreigners to go because I mean all in
all
them speaking English is one thing but
you just have your smartphone for
everything yeah you could Google
translate everything yeah
um so the reason why I wanted to do this
podcast even though like typically this
podcast obviously we either have serious
sadness or we're joking about a lot of
stuff I do want to help people when they
travel when I was younger traveling
wasn't a part of my life like I didn't
think it was important right I wanted to
stay in my small town and just you know
eventually get married have kids and
just do stand up locally or whatever
yeah I didn't have like lofty dreams
like I my idea of what I could what I
was capable of was very very low like I
didn't really think much so you have to
understand too like growing up your
whole life you're called dumb you're
called stupid or whatever me too so the
only thing that you think you're capable
of is what people expected out of you
that's so interesting because I've
thought of as differently it's like I
want to get out of here because I don't
want to be dumb or like I don't want to
be called late with labels yeah like it
never it never I don't think if I you
know having to think about I don't think
it really made me feel terrible per se
of course it felt didn't feel great but
you when you get told that you are on
that your ceiling is here this is all
you actually expect out of yourself
right
um when I decided to leave is when I
decided that hey I can do more right
like I I don't have to stay not that I
hate my my hometown I love Sacramento
like Sacramento is my hometown it's like
my heart and soul it's where I grew up
uh my closest friends are there too
everything about that place I love but
you know the hard part about being in
this in a
small Hometown is that you get small
Hometown Vibes and nobody wants to leave
and basically after you graduate and you
have a job usually that kind of you know
that's like the whole your whole book is
written at that point
um for a lot of people not uh that I in
my personal opinion that are in
Sacramento I think a lot of Sacramento
people can agree
why my living situation was a little bit
different because I grew up in Diamond
Bar and I would say majority of the
people left that City to explore you
know what they want to do and for me
personally I had this dream of you know
traveling around the world and Japan
happened to be the first place where I
lived abroad alone and I didn't know the
language I didn't know the people I
really just had to figure out how to get
around
and back then we didn't have smartphones
so I literally took my electronic
dictionary write everything down
communicate with them I didn't even
think about that yeah like back then you
cannot use your smart I mean there was a
smartphone so use your dictionary to
communicate with them or you figure out
how to memorize everything to get around
and that's what I did damn I didn't even
think about that in my mind I was
thinking that you had Google translate
with you but it was such it was so long
ago oh yeah because for me what I would
do like if Mariel wasn't there I showed
her like Google translate has this thing
where you could speak in English and in
real time with maybe about like a 10 5
or 10 second delay depending on the
internet it will say what you say in
English in Japanese and when they speak
they can speak in Japanese and they'll
translate it back that's what I'm saying
but it's so much more convenient for
foreigners to travel now because they
have that and it's like accurate you
could get by by using that my friend
Linda just went to Japan and she doesn't
speak Japanese and she said that's how
she got around she got a haircut she I
don't know went to like random stores by
herself and was perfectly fine yeah I
mean it's it's very very doable like
like I said for us if or for me anyways
it was just easy because you could speak
Japanese and it just made my life a lot
easier so it was kind of nice but um I
wanted to to do this podcast because
everybody has been asking like I think
there's a lot of things that when people
talk about traveling to Japan they just
don't talk about and it's like the
important things right for example
suica card oh yes um Jr passes yes these
things that are important for you to get
around and for you to be able to save
money without having to constantly get a
taxi because you don't know how to use a
subway system right the subway system
definitely a lot of people do use right
but it does get a little complicated
every now and then oh I knew so here's
the thing when we're planning out our
Tokyo trip I've never lifter nor got
around unless I had a friend with me who
was Japanese so I was in your situation
where they just took me around but I do
remember how complicated it was because
I've been my friend who was living in
Tokyo was like oh this is a little bit
complicated because there's like
different companies that run each line
and at that time I was like I have no
idea what you're saying but okay but I
remember that so I did my research to
figure out what it is and it turns out
Jr pass like for example I'll mention
one thing is that Jr pass is a great uh
pass to have if you're gonna be there
for a week and you're gonna be traveling
around down a lot using the public
transportation and shinkansen so we'll
start there right so how would people
get a Jr pass
nowadays again so much more convenient
you just literally type in Jr pass on
Google it will link you to the main
website everything is in English and
basically you purchase a ticket on the
website and close to your traveling date
they will mail you a receipt you take
that receipt you take it to Japan with
you and in one of the main stations they
are they have Jr station uh yeah Jr
station you go in there you show the
receipt and they'll give you a pass yeah
so Muriel before I mean before we left
she got this thing in the mail I had no
idea what it was apparently that was the
receipt so like for us we when what was
the what was the airport that we Narita
so we landed in Narita right you
obviously go through everything there's
a lot of people who speak English you'll
see a sign that says Jr pass or whatever
whatnot right and those you'll see a
bunch of people line up there and
essentially what people are doing and by
the way if you're if you want to get it
there of the day of it's a lot more
complicated right
they are I'm not sure what the rules are
I wouldn't suggest that I would say get
it in advance yeah because you don't
know how long the line's gonna be and
you want to make sure you do get one
yeah so that Jr pass is going to be
important right and so the Jr pass
essentially is going to be allotted for
the amount you can set it for the amount
of days that you are in uh Tokyo I think
there is either seven days or a couple
weeks or more yeah yeah um and so within
those lot of days you get this paper
ticket it's pretty sturdy right but it's
not going to be like a plastic card so
essentially that's going to be the thing
that you put into your the the the the
ticket vendor that allows you to use the
Jr line all across Japan right or
wherever you can and just a heads up for
those people who want to use that uh in
order to know if they are Jr line or not
um basically anything that starts with a
J is the Jr line yeah and so what we
mean by that well this is the other
important part too right you have the
option of going on two different train
lines right those two train lines are
owned by two different companies and
they go to you can technically go to the
same spots using one line but if you use
these two simultaneously you could
switch from Jr to using your suika card
uh s-u-i-c-a and you could basically get
that card at the vending stations right
so it costs a certain amount of money to
get the card that you get it on hold
then you add money into it it's
important for you to get both cards so
you can get to places a lot faster if
not you are allotted to only the Jr line
and then you have to use that one and it
goes in circles other times if you find
a spot you'll go to the Jr line and then
you could cut through that route using
the suika to get there like literally 15
minutes faster so the benefit of having
both of these is if you want to use your
time efficiently then get the sleeka
card if not you could take the longer
route taking Jr line or walking
but if time is priority for you having
both of these it would be recommended
and the reason why we also recommend
having that silica card is that
technically you could go to the each
station and purchase a ticket it just
takes a lot longer whereas like a car
you just literally scan it yeah and you
just what Dave and I did was we held the
Jr pass and seek a car in our hand and
we just constantly swap it so we would
take one Jared pass and we have to
transfer then take out the jarapass
again and then switch to suika card and
then sweep a card again and switch it
and there's just constant changes
um and we only did that because it was
the most uh fastest route and it's easy
to get around because Google Map will
tell you exactly where to go yeah and so
Google Maps will also give you the
option obviously you could just tap if
you just want to go use the Jr line or
if you want to get to this destination
as fast as possible they'll Google Maps
will already tell you okay use this DIY
and switch this to this week and then
you can go this way and here's a huge
hint which I learned when I got there
because I was asking one of the
employees how to get to another line and
she pointed out look at the platform
that's the best way to find out like
where to go and oh my God after she told
me that I was like this is so much
easier because if you say oh take the
Yamamoto line there are two ways that
you go on Yamamoto line you go either
south or north and if you take the wrong
side then you're going the opposite
direction so instead of looking at the
Yamamoto line
only look at the platform as well and
the Google Map is 100 accurate with the
platforms oh so it'll say Yamamoto Line
This platform yes so those two depending
on where it goes have different
platforms yeah look for Yama so look for
the line name and then the platform and
match those two up and then go because
if not and you're sitting on a train and
then you're like hmm where am I did you
realize you just went five miles the
other way yeah and then you have to go
back go go off the train go to the other
side get back on and then go all the way
back again which has happened to us only
once during the trip yeah and that's
because I got that tip of the platform
number yeah
um
I think that part right there is very
important for people because I know
sometimes when people travel they get a
little frustrated and they'll just go
straight to the taxi that's why I did
the first time I was in Japan because I
didn't want to have to deal with all
that stuff so I was like you know what
just taxi it takes a lot longer
um obviously during the first time went
to Japan I was really fat so walking was
not was not very pleasant for me so
taking a taxi with a group of like 20
people because JK was the one that took
us oh I see so taxi is the worst because
not only it's hella expensive but it
takes so much longer than the Subways
yeah so
um
that's really important so second tip
that I want to talk about when when
traveling to Japan
um is food right so
you know we're we're now in a
technological age where if you look up
best things to eat in a certain area
you'll see
30 40 different blog sites talking about
the best places to have something right
and what you'll notice when you go to
these blog sites even before I went to
when we went to Japan this time is that
these blog sites say the exact same food
spots and maybe it's because it is
popular or maybe it's just because a
tourist wrote this and then another
tourist found it and so it kind of
becomes like this cyclical thing where
you see the same thing over over and
over again
um Japan does have food reviews right
it's just not as prevalent as in the
state so
um I've said this before and I think
somebody misconstrued this when I said
Japan doesn't have a yell like it
doesn't have Yelp there are other apps
they have Google reviews that have it
but what I mean by that is that it's not
as strong as it is here like over here
you open up Yelp you'll see every single
restaurant in the area has a review
right whether it's 40 up to 100 to a
thousand uh for what we've seen is that
most of these reviews at most will have
200 to 300 reviews right and about like
80 of those reviews were from foreigners
right if you go I forgot there's a
couple of apps that somebody told me
that were in Japanese but it's like
their version of Yelp but even then I
saw it it had like maybe 100 reviews
Japanese are not really all about you
know saying negative things of others
and putting it out there maybe that's
why it's not a big thing yeah um because
when I yeah when I was looking online it
was hard to find something that's more
local that's what I was trying to do
because I looked at these I was like
well we've been to Japan so many times
do we really have to go to these like
the new hot places or can we find
something that's more local populated
not so like you know yeah well what do
you call it a hole in the wall type of I
will say this right so here's one of my
biggest tips if there is Common Street
Food
that has a lot of reviews for example
okonomiyaki
um takoyaki right and you see on this
blog site that says this takoyaki spot
is the best most likely theirs is just
as good as the next one over there with
my new differences right takoyaki in
general is pretty good any stall that
you go for example one of the biggest
places that you're going to go to if you
travel to Osaka is that night market
right and I read on every blog site you
have to go to this takoyaki spot they
all taste the same yeah all delicious
yeah whether they have a hundred people
in front 20 people in front or 10 people
in front that's what you have to be very
wary of right well somebody who is a
tourist that goes Japan once and they
write this review of the best spots do
you think that they ate takoyaki 30
times yeah they didn't they didn't eat
takoyaki at 30 different spots to say
which one is the best they all taste the
same they're all just as good and that's
another thing is that the standard of of
food in Japan it's a lot higher hope
especially Tokyo and Osaka they're known
for their food so it has to be good by
default yeah and then there are really
good ones but I don't think the ones
that are super popular on Instagram are
the only places yeah so if you go to
these spots right and you feel like
you're missing out because you didn't
get to eat the spot I guarantee you look
what they're making and just Google it
somewhere else somebody will be serving
something very similar and it's going to
taste almost exactly the same if not
better or depending on the situation yep
right because I think one of the things
that I really like about Japanese food
is that
this is a criticism that I heard from
Joe's mom so Joe's mom says like the one
thing that Japanese people are kind of
like
they like coming to America and a lot of
Western countries because we're more
experimental with food so there's a rule
and then we break those rules and then
we create something new in Japan they do
have versions that they have like
Japanese like Parisian Bakery they have
pizza or whatever whatnot right they
have their version of pasta but once
that rule is broken this is where that
broken rule stays nobody's evolving from
that doing something else in zany so
you'll have a lot of like traditional
food in Japan that's really really good
you get tonkatsu from one spot that's
really popular if you Google in the area
there's 20 spots that are also popular
they all pretty much taste hella good
yeah you know like you won't regret
going to the one next door just because
they have less people in there it's just
everyone's so good and actually I feel
like a lot of the times we really like
the ones that we just walked in walked
in yeah randomly we're just like this
place looks good let's give it a shot
and it was just like like that takoyaki
it was so good yeah it was so the
takoyaki that we had actually in
Shinjuku right in Tokyo we actually like
better than the takoyaki that we had in
Osaka and Osaka is known for takoyaki
yeah so you know like I said the food is
pretty good all around so you know
you're gonna go on Instagram you're
gonna see foodie people go to these
really popular spots that's like an hour
and a half wait for us we don't like
waiting for food right if we look at
that and we go okay there was a spot
that we wanted to try it was a place
that did uh like these donburi's right
with uh tuna and then this amount of
ikura right
I looked at other places around the area
that has something very similar to it
and it was half the price yep and we
didn't have to wait for three hours and
it was [__] delicious yeah right so
people will do similar things that you
can um well here's a question then how
do they find those non-popular places
I think what I what we were doing too is
that honestly you could tell if you just
kind of look at the menu and you see if
there's people inside if there's people
inside that are locals it's probably
going to be pretty good yeah like here's
a great example right you go to I don't
know how many times I've seen this we
have ichiran Ramen in New York and loss
we have it here right yes ichiran is
delicious yes it's very good now mind
you
when you go to Japan and you go to
ichiran
you're not going to get any different in
any different experience that you will
if you when you go to New York and you
get or whatever locations that they're
at they're all pretty much the same
they're pretty consistent each other
Ramen is delicious however I've had
infinitely better Ramen from hole in the
wall spots with nobody there better than
ichiran right in my personal opinion
right
um that's how many ramen shops are in
Japan so if you go to specific spots
that you feel like you're missing out
right I guarantee you just look out in
the area and you'll find something else
that'll be just as delicious or even
better what was our two worst Food
experiences
the the Omakase one the expensive ones
yeah the most expensive meals that we
had were actually our worst experiences
and um if I could kind of quantify why
no matter where you go there's a certain
level of snobbery to New Age chefs yeah
right they feel that they're doing and
first of all like specifically in Japan
like when you see people do uh Yakitori
Yakitori is going to be pretty much the
same and the only thing that's going to
be different is the quality of meat
because everybody is very particular
about their skill set well this one that
we went to was you know we had got a
reservation we got there they had really
good reviews
um they're actually very popular not
only uh with tourists but also with the
locals so I was like oh my God we have
to go here and honestly the first like
maybe 30 minutes it was actually really
good we were able to get a reservation
we got seated we got our food real fast
and it was it was very delicious until
we had about a 30 minute map of nothing
coming through they forgot about us
completely yeah they completely forgot
about us and you know we're just being
patient maybe it's taking some time but
we thought I don't think they forgot
it's not that they're still working on
it they forgot about it so I called the
waiter and I was just like are we still
is it still coming around
he didn't even apologize he was just
like oh yeah yeah yeah well you know
you'll get it soon like I was actually
shocked how he responded because it was
just so uh
uh casual in a way that
he didn't apologize and as soon as he
said that he went to go talk to the chef
and within five minutes we saw our next
dish yeah he completely forgot and so
what we'll find out too
um and this is has to do with food but
not really when you guys are in Tokyo
right
Tokyo just like anything else there's
always something wrong when you live in
a city compact with that many people
right and what I mean by that it starts
to change people people in Tokyo and you
guys are going to say this when you
everybody who goes to Japan they go to
Tokyo first they go to osakan Kyoto
after right which is exactly what we did
um you will notice that people in Kyoto
and Osaka are infinitely nicer I know
they're so nice too nice maybe most
people who first go to Japan will
probably not notice this yeah right
because they're even their standard [__]
service is better than about 80 of
American Service yeah right only because
in the culture you're supposed to be
polite yeah but once you're around the
language and the people enough you can
sense microaggressions for example you
could tell when they don't want you
there they're annoyed that you don't
speak Japanese and I said I started
sensing that on the second day I'm like
because my now my the mysticism and the
wow is gone when you know when people
would talk to her serve us I'm like
you're irritated I could tell I was like
oh you're irritated too yeah and but
then the moment that we went to Kyoto
right
everyone's so nice yeah they got some
old-fashioned phrases that I heard in my
old Japanese book that I did here in
Tokyo like okini like I didn't hear that
at all in Tokyo of course yeah that's
not used in Tokyo also that's like very
dated to them I like it it's just like
here you know in New York or L.A it's
just work compact with people a city
messes people up yeah and it's like from
different counties different areas so
people are just like I care about myself
kind of uh Vibe whereas Kyoto is still I
mean a lot of the restaurants are still
run by Elders yeah and I think you know
it's proud of their culture but also I
think they just appreciate that people
come around and I don't know what it is
like you know we went to that one uh
restaurant called okuden in Kyoto next
to food
yeah yeah yeah oh right next to you
Inari Temple oh my God this couple just
made our day Awesome by the way service
does make food taste so much better it
really does and they were just like
having fun of like laughing with the
customers and it was so sweet to us yeah
they're just so sweet they're like oh hi
and just you know obviously they knew
that we're foreigners so they were just
like making sure that we understand
um and let me tell you something man and
there was this one girl two where my
where Mario was getting we were we I
love
um Japanese or like the Asian yellow
sweet potato so whenever I saw a stand
that was serving some type of dessert or
baked dish with it we had to go so this
girl like with the way she you know gave
Mario like her receipt or money back she
just tossed it at Muriel it was a young
lady young lady super rude I was like I
did not want to be there let me tell you
something if you ever wanted to motivate
me to learn how to speak Japanese is to
curse somebody [__] out like that's
how that's why I learned how to speak
Korean was so I could talk back to my
parents I would learn how to speak
Japanese but that's Korean culture
though with Japanese culture if you say
unless you learn anime style like you're
not gonna like that but then I would be
able to talk to him say like hey like
don't you don't throw money at my wife
that's really disrespectful yeah like I
could say that you know what I mean
yeah because young people too because if
that's how they want to roll in Japan
like young people want to roll like that
too we could roll back like that too
it's just now you know like like in
Korea like they kind of just like I
don't even know if it was mushy I think
it was just like that girl was just
unmotivated it wasn't to me but it was
just like I don't want to be here and
then she just without thinking kind of
tossed it I was like what the this
little girl but then again you know you
go to Kyoto and it's like nobody does
that everybody's really you know in
being respectful whether you're a
foreigner or not and yeah it's just
appreciate more there are definitely
things too like with food
um
like I'd say this too the food is going
to be really cheap uh if you're
especially you're coming from the US our
dollar is just a lot stronger than
theirs right now
um so you'll be able to eat a lot of
good food in general you're not going to
be able to eat everything that you want
to eat uh because it's it's like coming
to LA and saying I want to eat every
good food in L.A good [__] luck we
I've lived here for what 12 years now
it's impossible impossible impossible
yeah we did eat a lot but we also walked
a lot yes and there was a lot more
restaurants I wanted to try I just
didn't have the capacity it was like
once we had a really good meal we're
pretty much good for the next like four
or five hours and how many hours in a
day do we have to eat again like we can
well here's the thing we have like the
main meal and then we like Munchies for
the hours so we're not that hungry until
our next meal every time I saw a
sandwich I got a sandwich oh my gosh and
legit okay here's the thing we Splurge
we did not think how much money we're
gonna spend because other then those two
restaurants so it's expensive expensive
restaurants everything was pretty
manageable and they were in a good price
deal so we're like let's just have
whatever we want convenience store get
like 10 sandwiches if we want get all
the drinks and the total uh cost that we
got just for food was equivalent to the
transportation price and transportation
we were being very uh aware how much
money we're using because we knew that
taxi was super expensive we are both
working adults we make good money
um thank you so for for us
when we splurged we really did Splurge
but if we let's say we that if we ate by
the way when I ate I ate a lot he did I
mean like a ridiculous amount and it's
not just cheap food too right I'm
talking about really really good
restaurants
and even then
right if just to put it in perspective
if the amount of food that I ate here if
I ate it in the U.S it would have cost
me about five to six times more than
what we spent no doubt that's how that's
that's how much
like if you if you're not a person like
me and food isn't like your main draw
and you're more about the experience of
traveling and walking around you won't
spend anywhere near as much money as we
did on food so for example one of the
best meals that I ever had was this uh
tendon right it's this little spot that
Mariel found a lot of locals are there
this one we waited in line yeah but it
was first of all the original weight was
like 40 minutes it only took us like 20
minutes I know they're so sufficient
um
top three best meals I've ever eaten in
my life and I added extras it costs
about eight to nine dollars
that was with extras and I was stuffed
with a beer and then I ordered an extra
thing on top of that it was so damn
Delicious I damn near teared up as I was
eating it yeah it cost eight to nine
dollars now if you're a normal person
you wouldn't have been able to finish
that bowl no right because you finished
mine I got that and I ate some of yours
yeah if you're a normal person you would
have got a regular size it would have
cost you like six seven bucks oh that's
the great thing is that they actually
have proportion size so for right
there's a lot of rice bowls right you
could ask for extra rice regular or less
rice which is really nice for me because
I want to eat more things but not a lot
of quantity yeah that place like I said
we also the second best thing I ate
there was actually a freaking burger
from this place called Dragon burger
also next to fushi nari yeah the fushi
Inari Temple before you go to the to
Inari Temple uh in Kyoto you will see
this place called Dragon Burger it's
actually a burger spot that was started
up by this guy in the UK and he is known
for making amazing Burgers so he has a
Kyoto brush called Dragon Burger I know
corny ass name but literally
top two best burger I've ever had in my
life I have to say it was one of my
favorite Burgers too and this wasn't
something we researched this was just
walking by we passed by a couple of
times because it's right next to the
subway station we're like oh it kind of
smells good you know what let's give it
a try yeah we walked by and it just
smelled like beef fat like griddled beef
fat which was already great the the
onion rings and the french fries amazing
they had House made Coke that they made
with their own in-house made Coke syrup
and then club soda and it was [__]
delicious they had a cocktail made of
that as well too yeah service was
fantastic it was so good and by the way
we didn't eat at places twice because
there were so many things that we wanted
to eat we ate here twice because I just
wanted to eat it was so good it was that
damn good and here's the thing
I just thought of this right now that
place was run by all young people and
they were great and they were great
their service was amazing once again
they're in Kyoto yeah right I'm pretty
sure if they were in Tokyo and everybody
else is so high strung it might have
been a different vibe but definitely one
of the spots I know it's weird you guys
you want me to eat a burger in Japan yes
I want you to go eat that burger in
[__] Japan it's that good
um Ramen we went to the ramen Museum
see they're just too many places and
these are not places that you would find
online really like yeah it wouldn't be
on the Instagram hot places did we ate
this one place it was just a restaurant
do you remember the name of the the
sisters that opened up the beef spot oh
man in Osaka right yeah oh wow I was
like wagyu something something yeah wagy
sisters or whatever like I forgot I
forgot what it's called but they have a
set called the wagy sisters or sister
bowls or something it's based we think
we kind of like assume and I think it's
pretty accurate is that there are three
sisters
um young sisters who are running that
restaurant and they're the chef yeah
it's it's really good and I noticed it
from the jump because
you could tell by Body Language right
like I said I don't understand Japanese
but I know who the [__] the boss you
were observing a lot I was focusing on
the text like I focus she knows like I'm
a people Watcher I people watch like a
[__] yeah I mean you weren't
preoccupied I'm like looking at them and
I looked at her body language I was like
oh they own the place right they were
very chill and like casual too
especially because in Japan it's so male
dominated it's specifically in like
cooking roles as well
um unless like it's a small joint where
the the lady owns it with her husband or
she owns it by herself
um you usually don't see the men cower
in front of the lady yeah and then we
saw that I saw the body language I was
like oh they're the owners like they
don't they don't so when we walked in
what we saw behind the kitchen was there
were a few ladies running around and
then there were two men but these men
were at the corner just kind of
observing very quiet and the women were
actually the one very loud and very
active with the customers and we think
is that those three ladies or the ones I
know yeah and they're they were teaching
those men how to cook or something like
there was some I forgot what it was but
either way
um they had this at the time when we
went there they actually have it on
their menu as a set menu thing now but
when we went there it was just they just
opened up not too long ago so it was it
was
um like a special that they were having
but it seems to be like a set menu thing
now they have it they just advertise it
recently yeah because when we went there
it wasn't on the set menu it was like a
bonus thing so yeah it was like they
just opened up not too long ago and
that's like an introductory thing it was
really cool and it was very yummy very
very delicious again it's one of those
we're like check it out there's no line
so I'll give you guys a great example
too
um just to stick on this food Foods part
there's a very common
um Japanese beef bowl place right like
udon place right where they just do like
sliced seared meat with a special sauce
soy sauce like a sweet soy sauce and
they'll put like egg yolks green onions
um their versions of this like this
light cheese sauce all this stuff right
so it's a place called Red Rock Red Rock
is common like you'll see there's not
anybody in there to be honest with you
nope right and when we went in there it
smelled like like an older place where a
lot of people have been it was a little
dingy you know uh it was dark and not
really welcoming Vibe we were the only
people in there eighth came out super
fast I ate the stuff and I was like
I think it was like six bucks it was
really cheap yeah six bucks and like
nine bucks my thing was like nine
dollars I added a bunch of stuff and her
just like six bucks and it was what
fifteen dollars for the whole meal no
tip by the way in Japan there's no
tipping no tip and then I went to the
bathroom and I as I was uh doing my
business I saw this poster in the
bathroom like I think they have one in
L.A and so I told David I was like hey I
think they have this location in La too
checked it out and it was in Torrance
and ever so by the way we spent 15 bucks
for both of us the ones in Torrance
obviously because it has to be different
right of course it was like 40 bucks 30
bucks for One Bowl I was like holy [__]
I'm not gonna eat it here no I mean how
could you right it's just it's not a
it's not a casual dining experience but
over there we're just like we're hungry
let's just grab something yeah I I think
like you guys when when if you haven't
been to Japan you are going to love the
food experience right
um
if you're like oh I don't want to do any
of the tour stuff the tour stuff is fun
do it like we've I've we've been there
she's lived there I've been there
multiple times this time we didn't do it
because why I already did it yeah we've
already done it we want to experience
something else made cafes owl cafes
Shiba in all that stuff is fun don't not
do not not go there one of the things if
you guys are uh a Miyazaki fan Studio
Ghibli Park is one of those things that
you absolutely must go to it is amazing
like I am a huge Miyazaki fan so for me
it was awesome right we were [__]
exhausted getting there because the
shinkansen [__] exploded that day or
something
that day there was a typhoon that passed
by so it canceled literally almost all
the shinkans except for one except one
line and I thought I was gonna have a
panic attack because the amount of
people that just jam into that
shinkansen and the amount of people that
was in the subway station was Unreal
just to put in perspective like the shin
consent is never packed where we're
standing no it's usually so it was so
packed because there was only one train
available on a weekend yeah and for us
to get to our destination we were
standing with people literally like
three inches from our face for two hours
yep and that is not the shooting
constant experience at all it's really
comfortable so when that happened I what
I was going to freak out yeah I couldn't
breathe by the way that was for three
hours oh it was three hours it was yeah
we were standing for three hours and
then once we arrived to the destination
they wouldn't open the door yeah and
maybe another 20 30 minutes passed by
freaking out and it turns out we come
out there is literally us I would say
thousands of people just waiting waiting
to get in and they wouldn't let them in
because the train just was just so
messed up because of the typhoon but
kudos to those employees I seriously
applaud for them and they figured it out
though when we came back it was fine
that's true yeah that's amazing yeah
yeah
um so we talked about the food so oh if
you guys want to uh like Google food big
tip Google it in Japanese so find out
what the word is in Japanese whether
it's tonkatsu with burger or whatever
and then you'll see Japanese reviews pop
up
Pro tip if there's a three star next to
it it's a Japanese it's really good
Japanese people be out of rough
also if you want to have just like a
homemade style
um Bento set or like breakfast set look
for tae Shoku yeah uh how do you spell
that
e-i-s-h-o-k-u-ta that just means like a
meal set and it's really cheap very
yummy very simple Japanese breakfast is
like that much like Korean breakfast we
really don't have breakfast right it's
essentially the foods that we'll eat
even at dinner but these are like sets
well you'll have fermented vegetables
um some type of grilled fish or tonkatsu
spots or whatever
um when I was doing my food ratings
online some people were very confused
like well how was this tonkatsu spot
you know a 10 out of 10 and then you
gave this one which is like not look
that a 10 out of 10. it's based on price
if I went to a hole in the wall spot
right that gives you your Foods
instantly in about five minutes where I
get a ticket out and I sit down
clearly it's not this amazing Chef made
thing right it's something that's quick
and fast but that quick and fast meal
cost me
almost four bucks almost so it wasn't
even four dollars and it was a full set
ass meal that's a [__] it's a 10 out of
10 20 out of 10. oh yeah absolutely so
but if I go to the other restaurant
where I'm paying triple the amount and
it's [__] delicious it's also a 10
out of 10 based on the price there's
nothing in the United States that'll
give me a a uh oh yeah
right miso soup a little Tuna on the
side all this other stuff and then a
drink and then it's four bucks that [__]
would be easy 20 something dollars
that's the part that we really
appreciated and Miss is that we didn't
have to worry about how expensive things
were because they were just such
reasonable price yeah it was pretty
amazing like yeah I'll say this too
um
service is always going to be really
really good yeah right by default it'll
all have its standard it's going to be
really good if you're a coffee lover you
have to find very specific coffee spots
that'll be really good Ah that's the
thing coffee price on the other hand is
expensive it's about the same price yeah
if you find the ones that are a little
bit fancy uh yeah it'll be the more
expensive if you are in Kyoto favorite
Coffee Spot ever about us is this place
called about us
Champion
um coffee roast like Bean roaster there
um just very good coffee and also close
to fushi Nadi Temple yeah
we we stayed around that area so we just
kind of get to know the area and the
local places and yeah those three places
okay then Dragon Burger about us uh
first time goers uh if you want to go to
the tsukiji fish market
be my guest go there just know that the
price the prices there are inflated as
hell it's really [__] expensive there
you can get similar things and most
likely better places outside of that but
I do suggest you support the business
there buy a few things here and there
yeah it's still an experience it's still
a dope experience
um when I went to the tsukiji fish
market it was like three times that size
and then it was actually next to the
actual Fish Market before it got
relocated I went there when it relocated
and before it got this popular
um it was really fun got to try all
different kinds it kind of feels like a
night market yeah the tsukiji fish
market now is officially officially a
tourist trap yep um like I said is a
tourist trap still worth going if you've
never been yeah but
half the amount of restaurants now
quadruple the price it is pretty pricey
and ninety percent of people there are
not Japanese it's it's kind of crazy
like if the Japanese people that were
there were on a field trip no yeah yeah
yeah yeah so when I was there everybody
spoke English I'm like whoa this is not
because it didn't feel like Japan at all
and here's another thing usually we like
to go and try fast food just for the
sake of it because they do taste
different like McDonald's KFC we didn't
go to any of them yeah I didn't need to
uh I just didn't have the space for it
we really I was like I really want to
try that apple pie I really want to try
it but
just did it there were just so many
other things to eat yeah there's just a
lot of things to eat out there man so
don't be afraid like be be willing to
explore outside of like this recommended
list and you won't be disappointed and
think about it too like when you're in
Japan let's say like you only like Ramen
and you only want Ramen uh tonkatsu and
uh and soba right well guess what try
all the different restaurants the like
we went to a restaurant I had soba and
it was like highly rated the best it was
whatever and then we went to another one
and it was
like the first the restaurant that we
went to the first day that we just
walked in oh yeah it was good that'll
look good it's not on a review on the
radar at all and it was better than the
place that had a thousand reviews from
um from like tourists yeah and you know
what it almost felt like those those
ones that weren't on the list were just
a lot better I think they're also they
innovated a little more too they weren't
sticking to just traditional traditional
stuff yeah the one that was that's
popular that is very traditional yeah
which I think people would appreciate
but it wasn't something that
it was in our flavor Yeah a hundred
percent
um well we depending on what you guys
are doing out there
um if you're tall just know that you're
gonna bump your head on a lot of things
I smashed my head into so much [__]
um that's just the given was it that
small everywhere you went uh
specifically uh Kyoto because it's older
so oh really not Tokyo because a lot of
Tokyo places are their seats are so but
the height wasn't it was adjusted the
places in Kyoto the height wasn't I
smashed my head on so many things I'm
too busy looking down on my phone that I
don't know what's happening I smashed my
head on a lot of things interesting
um
so there is if you're a bigger person
it's it is going to be a little
uncomfortable
um if you want to go to Tokyo with the
group or six or seven I suggest not to
because or or eat all eat separately
because a lot of these restaurants that
you're going to really enjoy they
probably only seed about like 10 to 15
to 20 people yeah so um if you're
thinking about going in a huge group
like we did in Japan the first time we
had to split our Groot up group up by
like seven seven groups yeah just try to
go in Paris at most and another thing I
would recommend is really just follow
their culture rules yeah it's just it's
so pleasant over there because they
follow the rules and like for example
I've never felt so safe in bathrooms
yeah they're so clean I've never
encountered a toilet that smell that had
like pee all over the place like it's
just maintained so well no trash on the
streets
they don't really have trash bins
outside so you have to hold on to your
trash and just it's you gotta be
respectful with their culture and I hope
everybody has
study a little bit about what their
culture is like because
I love the fact that they can maintain
what they have because it's such a
pleasant experience as a foreigner like
the society is about like community and
at the same time personal responsibility
so the idea that okay I have this trash
I'm gonna hold it until I find a garbage
can because I don't want this country to
look trashy it's it's like a cult a
strong cultural identity obviously
depends a lot smaller so they're allowed
they it's a lot easier for them to
uphold this value so when you go to
Japan just be mindful of that as well
right because a lot of people they may
not say something but they're gonna
[__] hate you for sure of course
because they're just prone to even when
they confront you they'll be really
polite about it Korean people not so
much like if you're in Korea and you're
out of line somebody's going to check
you personally they'll be like hey hey
fix it yeah I cut that [__] out like
Korean people aren't as kind like that
um and even for me too when I was in
Korea when we were in Korea I'm not sure
if you noticed it but there's these
people that were super loud on the train
and then uh in Japan or Korea no in
Korea I think you were kind of like
sleepy and tired but they were super
[__] loud and it was like it was a
white dude that was an american guy oh
you might have been nodding off at that
point but it was a why do those American
guy and then he made eye contact with
somebody else that was American and they
were [__] loud as [__] on the train
and I just walked over with the guy you
know I tapped him and I was like don't
do that you know really yeah because he
was he was so loud like he was just so
I'd have to say that he knew he was
[__] up you know but they were just
like oh my God I was like bro come on
chill yeah I mean I I understand if
you're excited and everything but again
just read the room yeah read the room
just be respectful because at the end of
the day you're going into their culture
their country you want to experience
their culture the right way then you
have to make sure that you are
respecting that yeah there's a lot of
like cultural landmarks too that are
there right like it's it's a country
that's been around for a very very long
time so you know things are are
connected not only from like a cultural
standpoint but also very spiritually
like you'll see like temples all over
the place right so beautiful how you
behave is a reflection not only on
yourself but also from the country that
you're from right so if you do have like
Pride specifically I'm talking about
American people right I'm American as
well we're representing our country when
we go to another country so just be very
mindful of that type of stuff like when
I when I see people who are you know for
example there was something that really
irritated me like she knew too I was so
pissed
Services there was this greasy greasy
ass white dude
remember
right yeah yeah and I didn't even know
what he looked like no but from the he
was behind you from the sound of his
weeb ass [__] voice right I was
literally telling her like I'm telling
this [__] back here is talking
so much [__] about America right and I'm
like he's very loud too yeah very loud
and he's talking [__] about America to
girls because he's trying to get them to
like them right they're Asian girls
they're Asian girls and I'm like dude
this you [__] Benedict Arnold you
little sellout don't I like I'm the
Asian dude right I'm like get out of my
country man I wanted to tell him okay
get the [__] out of my country man
we don't want you here anyways my boy
America doesn't want your time here
anyways
what's going on
yeah you take your dirty little white
self and get the
Factory I wanted to do that so bad but I
sat there and I was like I guarantee you
this dude is a fat big old white dude
with facial hair long hair a flannel
shirt yes and she was cracking up
because that's exactly what he looked
like and he's just sitting there going
like oh I hate America America is so
disgusting it's so filthy and dirty like
I'm like oh
[__] we have beautiful places in
America too it's not like that
everywhere you jackass I know you just
like sitting there just try he goes oh
or the gun problem in America and let me
tell you something these two little
girls who they were clearly Chinese yeah
she was she was saying I would never
want to go to America oh yes you would
you you would love to come here I don't
know I don't know why
why are you saying so much bad things to
they're not even Japanese yeah like
what's the What's your deal man yeah and
why are you talking so much why aren't
the girls talking yeah at all yeah and
he's just trying to be Mr cool guy I was
like you you're such a you let me tell
you something being a dweeb and a loser
translates in all countries all
languages even if you don't speak the
same language it doesn't matter those
girls too sounded so uncomfortable
they're like kind of I'm like bro stop
get if I ever see you on my sweet sweet
soil the United States of America I'm
kicking that ass on out talking [__]
about my country I had like this
American flag of this either behind me
yeah the red hat I know I had a trump
hat on
I'ma make America great Again by kicking
you out starting with you mister
I was so pissed too bad we didn't see
his face
but you were so accurate that was
hilarious I just knew I I because those
type of guys are all there in Japan dude
by the way we had parties left and right
as well and the only person that we were
able to hear was here yeah because it
was so loud yeah so just you know I know
for myself too I have to be aware of
this Americans our voice is actually
very very loud so just be mindful and
you know just poke each other make sure
that your volume is in the right even
when I was walking around just talking
to her she had to remind me like your
voice is loud I'm like oh [__] it is
kind of loud he was in denial at first
yeah oh we want to talk [__] on this
part let's talk [__] all right because I
can't poop all right
oh or poop no no no no let's not talk
about that you know what was tripping me
out the most okay
now mind you I've grown up watching
anime my whole life right and when you
see these characters caricatures in and
these characters in animates right yeah
like that's clearly an exaggeration of a
human being that doesn't exist not true
there's this cab guy right literally
like if you if you've ever watched anime
have you seen like the loud businessman
that the cab guy that just chops it up
with everybody and has a very specific
laugh
she exists yeah yep we both looked at
each other we're like
he's a character what was the word that
you misused you said you wanted to go to
a prison oh
oh what was it oh I forgot what the word
was but I was trying to say a city and
he's like oh and he gave me he showed me
his face he's like yeah and I was like
huh I don't know it's just a city and
the city was um written in romantic it
wasn't in kanji so I was like I don't
know what it says but it says this and
later on I found out I was like holy
[__] she was doing this side at first I
thought he said like no no you can't
come in the cab but what he was showing
was handcuffs yeah because he was like I
can't take it to a prison why do you
want to go to a prison
right and he was so confused because she
could speak Japanese yeah so I was like
I'm so confused why why is he saying
that I have to go to prison or like
we're going to prison and it turns out
the the word was very similar and then
later on he was able to find out that oh
it's a town next door he was cracking
and he was cracking up like a Japanese
anime character yes
like that I'm like yo these people are
there was a pharmacist he looked like
have you guys seen Death Note one of my
favorite animes of all time right the
pharmacists look not like light yeah
like not like light but the oh what was
his name it was the guy that was trying
to catch
um he said if the the main FBI right I
don't know he was the main guy that oh
my God like that that was one of my
favorite it's because I'm running blank
today but either way it looked just like
him and I was shocked he's a genius guy
yeah I was like holy [__] these people
actually exist they're drawing things
off of real people I never thought of
that even like the harmonies and the the
old people
yeah I'm like that is a real person in
Japan trick me the [__] out because
sometimes I'll see American cartoons
like there's no yeah like this right
yeah but I feel now that I've seen these
Miyazaki films and I'm watching these
people and people watching I'm like that
is a person in the Miyazaki film and
that person is real how [__] odd is
that yeah it was pretty pretty amazing
yeah so just keep those tips in mind
traveling purposes
um Subway stuff very important be open
to new food trying Foods out find people
who are at a restaurant that aren't
tourists that there's a lot of like
salary men there that are sitting there
or just like families is probably going
to be really really good you know be
willing to explore things outside of
this recommended list because I
guarantee you that recommend like for
example
I live in Los Angeles for 13 years I see
the recommended food restaurant list
about 80 of I think is trash I'm like no
that's trash that's that's not what you
want to eat yeah it's the same thing for
when you go to these countries when
people who don't who aren't in the
cities that are locals that are creating
this list they probably don't know
what's best so try a few spots that you
wanna that you want to um go to on that
list but be willing to explore and try
new things and if you don't speak the
language guess what they're very very
accommodating you also have Google
translate make sure that you use that as
well yes
um
be polite keep the place clean and be
very culturally uh aware aware of what's
going on there keep your voices down a
little bit you know it doesn't mean that
you're not going to hear a loud person
but usually you'll hear that at bars and
like pop in City spaces which is where
it's appropriate oh so for example a
couple of rules that doesn't really
apply in a lot of other countries is
that when you're in the subway
don't talk on your phone don't talk
period try to whisper because in the
subway people just their culture is that
you want to be mindful of other people
so keep everything to yourself yeah and
another thing is when you're eating make
let's just say you're walking you found
like some snacks that you want to eat
eating and walking by default is not
really a thing in Japan yeah yeah
usually you're you have a designated
spot to eat and then you walk you might
see some people just eating and walking
I think I'm not sure like this was
actually my first time seeing certain
younger ones just eating ice cream and
walking around drinks are fine but food
by default they usually have a little
area where you sh you eat and then also
I think it makes sense not to eat and
walk there too A lot of people are going
to work and you're [__] bumping into
everybody you get food on somebody bro I
would be pissed yeah you know so just be
mindful of that there's like these
little cultural things that um you'll
you'll see it look it up online too so
try not to eat and walk
um keep your voices down when you can
and there's times where you could be
loud and excited and that's where those
touristy spots are that there's this
Cafe where you where there's a bunch of
like bodybuilder women that serve you uh
woman yeah oh my God it looks so fun
um where was this uh it's in Tokyo oh I
know there are men but another woman
there's like women who do it it looks
super we're fine but the food doesn't
look good so I didn't care for it it's
just more for the fun experience oh and
then um which side to walk on which is
so bizarre to me but different like
Osaka so everywhere else like in Kyoto
and Tokyo you're gonna be on the other
side so you're gonna be on the left side
right yeah yeah left side but for some
reason in Osaka you're on the right
other side and I asked my Japanese
friend why is that and they said well
they have their own rules yeah follow
the follow the crowd when you're walking
around if they're walking a certain way
follow that way if not you [__] up the
flow really hard like you just just look
at the arrows on the floor follow the
arrows on the floor and you'll be
perfectly fine if you're if you're
somebody who's going to that country and
be like well why can't I do something
just don't go
yeah you know there's there's a I I
think Japan is such a safe tourist spot
yeah because of the culture that people
have created there Korea is also a
really really fun spot to go to if
you're traveling very accommodating
towards tourists
um but those are the main tips I just
want to do a podcast on that
um because I said that I would we could
probably go into uh in depth in this but
I'm flying out soon tomorrow so we gotta
wrap up this podcast
um you can catch genius brain every
Sundays at 12 p.m I hope that helped you
guys out in your uh trip for when you go
to Japan
um that's my lady you could find her at
Mariel underscore underscore song and
once again Jesus Utopia we'll see you
all next time peace foreign